In this video, we'll be taking a look at how
to create different kinds of blueprints.
But before we do that, let's take a look at
the gameplay framework inside of Unreal Engine.
On this slide, we're looking at some of
the terminology that gets used when
considering the gameplay framework in Unreal Engine.
Some of these key assets we use are a pawn,
which would be the actor that we are controlling,
and that can also be used by AI.
Character would be a subclass or
a child blueprint of a pawn and has additional abilities,
like having a skeletal mesh or being able to walk or fly.
The player controller is the embodiment or
the soul of the player where
input and other data gets processed.
You can actually have your player controller
possessing different characters and
pawns throughout the same project.
Player state and game state are
more relevant for multiplayer scenarios.
But game mode is one we actually will look at,
and that's where we can actually start to
define in a particular level
things like the relevant pawn and player controller,
etc, that will be used in that level.
Now that we know what a game mode and a pawn and a character are,
let's look at how we can change what pawn we're using from
the default flying camera to the third-person game mode player.
Here inside of Unreal,
we need to open our World Settings window.
Here we see an option for a game mode override.
It was already imported into this project,
but in case you didn't,
if we come to the Add feature or
content pack and add the third-person character content pack,
we will see here in our drop-down BP third-person game mode.
This sets our default pawn class
to that of the third-person character,
and then these other parts
of the gameplay framework are left as default.
But now when we press play,
we will see our third-person character out and about in
the world and we can control them using
a fairly standard WASD space to jump.
We'll notice though that with
our current collision settings on our imported FBX,
we cannot go on top of it yet,
so we will look at how we can jump on
that literally in a few more slides.
In the next video,
we'll look at creating an animation blueprint to
link our imported animations with our character.